We put them on our store, I don't recommend them for people.
On the last page of the genetics test,
you listed tumor suppressor genes,
and one of them highlighted was rock eye.
So when we look at
your tumor suppressor genes,
we look at all the tumor suppressor genes
in the tests that we run
and what the tests for.
So you had,
if I highlighted it,
you had a lot of rocker genes.
Now it might not have been the specific rocker genes
that your medical doctor is looking for that is really dangerous,
but if you still have a lot of rocker genes defected,
defects, I still want to support that.
So the support for rocker defects is tumor per human.
So knowing this much,
I made recommendations.
So when I look at your genetics,
I make treatment decisions and make recommendations based upon these things.
So if I made a recommendation,
that's what I made it up.
So the oncologist want to be to take a genetic test.
Now they're just going to run like 25 genes or something like that,
which is just fine.
Let them do it.
They want to do it.
If your church will cover it,
that's just fine.
I see now that last page that curcumid is indicated
for three or four of my tumor suppressor genes.
That's why I recommend curcumid.
Yes.
Sorry.